you I've never had kids and I want to
ask you is it fulfilling uh well I'll be
real be real be real is that uh as an
Asian person it will give you more
driver to be ruthless when people try to
hate you you keep working on your craft
make sure they have a good life as
agents so it's not going to slow your
career it's gonna it's gonna enhance it
yeah yeah I think so yeah yeah it didn't
ruin my career they didn't ruin like I'm
gonna do something I can't because I was
a kid they gave me more energy and the
faith to do it I mean if I have two
songs I'll be I'll be more powerful but
you know you can't have everything
yeah yeah my daughter is she's she's
very she's very smart yeah she's a
Savage
um what's who's gonna be your next
boyfriend now I want to find a guy like
I don't Asian white black what as I mean
has to be like attractive I have to be
attracted to that guy of course of
course I have to like I need to like
like really respect his whatever he's
doing let me ask you that see this guy
right here George
hi George yeah do you think that's
attractive uh I wouldn't uh
this Asian guy are you Asian what did
you think he was Latino I think you are
like half right
well Korean he's full Korean he looked
like he can be like one of those like a
crazy uh rich Asian half white asian
guys which one yeah maybe that's good I
hate them because they just find the
real Asian guy Bobby Lee can be the
Asian guy like he's an Asian love story
when you have a half white asian guy
because because he's better on the
screen Oh Henry Golding yeah yeah he's
like he he doesn't look Asian he looks
like he's half asian yeah that's a
[__] too like he looked like I want
somebody like an Asian like a Bobby Lee
yeah same like in the Phil in the
Philippines is that same [__] they
always choose like that they're not
they're not better actors they're just
whiter whiter yeah you know look at that
that's not Asian that's [__] George
Lopez when he's hot
yeah yeah that's true that guy's Asian
yeah Malaysian look at those he's
extremely handsome but I know what you
mean like was it that hard to put a full
Asian guy yeah I want the Bobby Lee I
know but can I say something I did ADR
in a movie the other day and what and
you know it was a pretty big movie so
you're at Sony and it's like a gigantic
screen right and once my head hit the
screen I went am I at my own head like I
startled myself oh
that's me that's me that's me like I was
shocked by it because we don't see our
faces so so yeah
I mean yeah oh please I see that's my
dream for you I want you to be in like a
rom-com and like really have full-blown
sex scenes with a hot chick yeah like
Jonah Hill with your people I hated that
yeah
how does the black woman Miss Jonah Hill
I and then they didn't show any of like
the amazing I never thought about that
but yeah true yeah sure they didn't have
any of the like make out the sex scenes
nothing is that graffiti I'm gonna like
I don't want to see feet
their feet are Giggles right you just
don't have the sex oh that's right
that's right they just show the feet and
the songs
yeah yeah it's you know what it's like
it's yeah I mean it's always been like
that
yeah I mean if you're not a sex symbol
they just don't write scenes like that I
don't think I'll ever be in a sex scene
I want to see his ankle fat
but also Jonah looks great there so
different show his
one of the nicest guys I've ever met
then show him [__] I know he's like
one of the sweetest guys he's always
been so nice I mean he's also gone out
of his way to say hi to me that guy's
just a really nice guy man [__] look
at him and he looks like a man yeah why
and she's beautiful we should just see
them [__] yeah they didn't even kiss
on camera they did it I CGI did it no
yeah why the CGI kiss but what if they
had those things they tested it and
didn't test well what to who that's true
like who are you testing it to there's
many me's out there that I'm like I want
to see all of it yeah that's true you
never see it you know I like I wish the
whale had a gnarly sex scene
[Laughter]
and then put another person in there and
just have a [__] 20 minute you know
them real like real lifting up the
stomach you know what I mean I would
have watched that in the movie theaters
on opening day yeah I would have yeah me
too I bring my Vaseline you know who
knows what else that's gonna do but I
would love to see like hey you gotta
scoot over this way because I can't get
an angle
I'm not being rude I'm just saying I
want to see two obese people in a sex
scene it's like with him and I we're
dating like Fig Newton I found a fig
newton
what that's yeah Fig Newtons yeah
they're delicious when him and I were
dating like the first time he tried to
do doggy yeah there we go like that's
what I'm saying like we need to see that
on screen like it couldn't happen yeah
like he had to like wear like platform
here yes or else like he just couldn't
read my [__]
what's his name like a Tom Cruise
that's right can I say I don't want to
be offended by it but there's one girl I
had sex with right Reese a couple months
ago and she goes I've never come so fast
with you I go why because she goes the
the fat above the fat above where the
pube is I've never seen it like you know
I mean I have a pouch so it rubs against
my [__] yes and I don't say yes no
because that's how it is don't say yes
all right and I and I I didn't know how
to like respond I was like oh cool right
but then I'm like I have a fat she
wasn't talking about my belly the fupa
yeah you have your fat upper [__] yeah
positions for tall women who are dating
shorter guys yeah yeah so this is
apparently supposed to help obviously
okay this is not true that's helped for
you okay no that doesn't help not not
true imagine me doing that with anybody
yeah that one the prison style is my
favorite kind that's hot this one would
help you Bobby that one is that would
help you is he doing his taxes what the
[__] around here
oh this one we've never tried babe
have we ever tried that and you can do
push-ups I feel like I'm still doing all
the work oh yeah this is that I don't
have no idea yeah yeah that's it yeah
but I would love to see you know I mean
just different kinds of people yeah two
black people making love that'll be the
hottest thing ever that's just two
people making love a blind person no
because you still have to have Direction
Marco Polo
yeah
something like if they're making up with
somebody who's not his small tits like a
braille yeah all right exactly is that
the friend no no yeah exactly you have
to there's you know if you're two blind
people making love you there's got to be
communication yeah yeah I mean I'm in
here yeah right right yeah oh you're in
the living room yeah I mean it's like
that kind of thing that's so hot yeah
yeah I would love to see that that'd be
hot and sexy you know anyway
um you're gonna be in a movie you're
gonna be a very big star and I don't
want you to worry about it because you
have the work ethic and I think you're
very pretty thank you that's really nice
from a Korean uh yeah that's a lot was I
nice to you or no you're super nice you
always
you're nice to everybody and and you're
always humble and that you when people
you know